former Republican House Speaker Newt
Gingrich was one of Donald Trump's most
outspoken surrogates in the presidential
election and continues to be a strong
supporter he's also the co-author of a
new thriller novel out today called
vengeance speaker Gingrich welcome what
is going on here I mean when you'd have
a leading Republican chair in the
Foreign Relations Committee and the
president is lashing out against him
when he needs his vote in the Senate
well look I think they'd be a lot better
off to get together for lunch and get
over it
Trump automatically hits back at every
and anybody just it's an instinctive
goes back to his New York days and it
seems to be virtually uncontrollable and
he thought that Corcoran said something
that had befriended him so he hit corker
support corker who's now liberated hit
him back I think it's not helpful to the
country it's not helpful to the
Republican Party and I think but I also
think you see Bannon on the right and
you see the people for example opposing
senator Feinstein on the left and you
have this this growing fractionalization
on both sides that I think is sort of
the the arrow we're in right now so you
have an Tifa and all these left wingers
over here and you have all right winners
over here and none of them are happy
with the world as it is
so they yell about it let's talk about
how this might impair although the
Republican agenda we're a week away from
a budget vote that is crucial in terms
of the president's attempts to get tax
reform done how does angering members of
your own party how it helped that effort
it doesn't mean I'm not going to sit
here I think Trump is a remarkable
figure I think he's a historic figure
he's certainly probably the biggest
change agent since Andrew Jackson in the
1820s and 1830s but I do think there are
things he doesn't understand about the
American system and Bannon has the same
problem we don't have a parliamentary
system we don't all get elected to march
in lockstep House Senate House members
win Senate members win presidents win
and they got to learn to work together
and that's been probably the biggest
weakness has been not finding a way to
work together and the truth is the
president will not get his major things
done without bob corker do you believe
what corker said that it could be
leading towards world war three this
kind of behavior that the president
reflects in the rhetoric he
look I think we are extraordinarily
dangerous time I think if you look at
North Korea which has rejected Bill
Clinton rejected george w bush rejected
barack obama we've had over almost 30
years now the north koreans cheerfully
saying we're going to build a nuclear
weapons that can reach the US and we're
gonna build weapons and missiles that
can reach the US that's not donald trump
that is the culmination of three decades
of failed policies part of what
vengeance my new novels about is
terrorists selling to super tankers of
oil to the north koreans for nuclear
material which did not weapon the
material which they can then use to
create dirty bombs for the US and we
need to understand we have enemies
across the planet it's not a vertical
it's not us North Korea it's us and a
range of enemies who would destroy you
anybody rain in the president no I mean
the president's terrain himself in what
are the implications for the Republican
Party here if there is not a single
legislative victory at a time when
Republicans control all three breaks
government there's a guy who used to
come by and tell you that I thought
Donald Trump would win they're gonna get
a tax cut they're gonna get a tax cut
because the country wants a tax cut the
country needs a tax cut not tax reform a
tax cut the wood miners are the tax cut
meat can come through tax reform but
what really matters is people will have
more money in their pocket I carry
around the the Paul Ryan postcard size
really do carry I really do carrying
because I think this this is what
Republicans ought to do talk less about
each other more about tax cuts will be a
lot better for picking a fight with bob
corker have implications as far as that
tax or of course it does that's why I
hope the two of them will have lunch get
over it I'm not sure Corcoran golf so
that that technique won't work but have
lunch get over it and let's move on and
help the country Steve Madden told me
that you were offered a number of jobs
in the White House when the president
was going through his transition period
what jobs did you turn down oh I didn't
turn down any specific job the president
said what did I want he had just decided
I would not be vice president which I
always knew was gonna happen but he used
me to sort of keep you guys busy while
he was picking Mike Pence so I think
doing a great job as vice president and
I said to him I want to be a strategic
advisor so I'm working with the vice
president on space I worked a lot with
with
the national security people on run for
example the Iranian agreement and work
to have worked a lot on health and
working on the DES you can tell I'm
working for the tax cuts and you can you
agree that we should withdraw from
absolutely certification I'm asking does
he think we should withdraws
Trump is suggesting only to do with the
Congress has nothing to do with do I
think I don't think you can say what the
president has said in judgment on the
Iranians and then turn around and
pretend you're gonna be and then the
Obama tradition of I didn't really mean
it so that's I should say by the way one
person who did say yes was my wife who
was up to be the best of the Vatican and
that's why she can't be here to talk
about all this the elephant her seventh
book yeah thirty second book something
like that 32nd yeah it's a problem most
mostly nonfiction but we've really
enjoyed creating actually you'd like her
Brook grant is a marine major and she is
our central figure we also have a woman
from Mossad and we have a Saudi and
something which is really happening in
the Middle East we have the Saudi and
the Israeli working together to try to
stop the terrorists evil read it in the
White House yeah
speaker Gingrich good to see you thank
you so much for being here